hey everyone welcome to the world air
podcast i'm james marshall and this
episode is brought to you by puresport
cbd
and straight face and straight face is a
there's a new partner have come on board
who sell
sharp five blade razors delivered to
your door at the cost of a three blade
razor from the supermarket
it's an awesome setup if you love your
clean shave and you've run out of razors
make sure you go give these guys a try
you can do so by heading over to
straight face dot co dot nz
use offer code lads l-a-d-s
put that in the promo code and you'll
get a whopping 50 percent off your first
order
definitely worth a try make sure you do
that if you have any issues with that
head over to waterlab.com and all the
information is on there
and also the merch is going to drop soon
so make sure you go over and check that
out
support this merch so we can help grow
this podcast all the profits will go
back into this podcast so i can deliver
you guys a better product if you're
enjoying the podcast please support
the podcast by getting yourself some
merch the merch is going to drop on the
30th of april remember that date
and get ready to wear some awesome
woodland gear
but anyway roll the intro
[Music]
you like that don't you what a man and
wow do i have a lad on the show for you
today one of the most
influential lads that i've played with
today's guest he not only won the item
cut with taranaki he also won super
rugby with the hurricanes
and as well as that he's represented new
zealand at sevens and he spent the last
few years over in japan playing and
making some serious yen
but throughout his career he had plenty
of setbacks and a lot of injuries
but throughout his career he was always
doing one thing and that was working he
is
the fridge he is an absolute lad it is
welcome brother thanks for coming on
the fridge thanks for having me you've
got the most appropriate nickname in the
game the fridge you never stopped
working throughout your career
oh such a legend i actually got a
message today they were like
why are you called the fridge or why are
you calling uh
i was like it's jimmy every time i walk
into the gym you were always rolling
it was just me and you in the gym early
morning
[Laughter]
right you've been the fridge throughout
your whole career and even post career
it looks like you're still
you still haven't turned off you're
still working it looks like you're doing
all sorts of good stuff so what are you
up to at the moment
uh so now i've uh i've uh hung up the
boots so
i've done a footy uh just stayed away
from footy now i'm just going to um
you know into this freelance photography
videography
um content creation vibe now and it's um
still good eh
kind of grinding away in like a
different sort of way no idea
living in the office saying not even hit
the gym not hit the road
so why did you leave rugby what what
happened there was an injury or
you just had enough no i think it was
the last couple years
um i had one of those
nights before the game where i was just
like just just like ah
now we got a game tomorrow and i kind of
dreaded it yeah and the
um gearing up in the morning for a game
that's like late afternoon at night and
then
you know your weekend's gone straight
and i was like ah
i got over at a big day yeah then plus
you get injured and then you're
rehabbing all the time and i think
that's why i think that's why
the fringe came and they yeah you were
injured
yeah you had such a bad run of injuries
though yours was like next level
yeah it was just injury after injury
after injury but but is the body all
right now
yeah the body um holds up um
i did have a wee um let's get into that
you know when you catch the fit in this
bug yeah for a moment there yeah
and i was mad i was grinding every
morning
after christmas after the christmas
break i just didn't go back
i've gone missing
[Laughter]
you said you've been doing some
photography some of that stuff that
you're doing is
is next level it's awesome to see so
when did you start getting into that
sort of stuff
um i think it was um just from traveling
around you know obviously when
i'm playing sevens and stuff where we're
traveling the world and
and all that and you just you're always
just taking photos and
um you know you try to do these little
cool videos and you put it together and
i mean
and then um in japan obviously when i
earned enough
to buy me a camera i was like oh here we
go and then yeah
and then man after that i just caught
the bug and i was just
i was all self-taught like all youtube
and then after that just i just
caught on to it and i just called the
bug in and now i just can't stop
putting content together graphics and
videos photos
it's just become the thing yeah that's
awesome and is that sort of why you gave
up rugby because you're just enjoying
creating stuff so much more than you
were rugby
oh 100 i reckon that's uh that was why i
think i found something that i liked
and loved outside of rugby yeah and i
was just like nah this is it
you know you you didn't have to train
hard
didn't have to eat well i mean
now i'm living the dream here i just sit
on my computer i have probably code
zeros and copy parts every morning
i'm getting sweet
living the dream so are you working for
yourself now doing this
yeah so now i just i just feel like for
myself do my own stuff um
and then uh have a few clients and stuff
like that that i do work
work with yeah and just heaps of other
mates you know a lot of mates that we've
played with they
in this day and age that uh
entrepreneurship yeah
lifeway you know and everyone's needing
personal branding and
and help that way so that's kind of
where it's kind of
good that's how i'm getting my workers
just relationships with all our mates
yeah we've played with footy that's
awesome mate and you're obviously doing
some stuff ferrari because i'm seeing
some pretty hissing graphics coming up
ferrari at the moment
yeah oh i mean
they've always talked about um doing
stuff together for a while yeah
and then um once he once i met joseph
started um they wanted to do this thing
called uncommon
that's just been released he uh he
messes through and he was just like hey
where you
got this thing coming up and then next
thing you know we're
we're putting some stuff together and
stuff like that so
it's so good yeah i got the friends i'm
excited
[Laughter]
and you've got your own podcast too i
listened to a couple of those today i
could see it far away
oh the [ __ ] was dead yeah it's just the
boys here right yeah that's so
funny man you guys are top dudes we're
just on there just now
just cracking up having a laugh and just
pushing that polly movement and just
rugby
in general and other things polly food
and
i mean you know that stuff hey my wiss
[Laughter]
i was listening to i was like man i need
to get on this one this one
oh
[Laughter]
yeah yeah are you even doing some good
stuff there
oh mate i've got some i've been lucky to
have some good guests on like yourself
and um being able to go through some
some of their journeys because it's
that's interesting uh going through
everyone's journey you feel like you've
played with
someone and you know them really well
and then you sit down and have a podcast
with them and you learn so much about
them or
yeah so much things that you you never
actually realize when you're playing
with them you never actually picked up
on so it's been really cool to see it
from that point of view
so we're doing podcasts every week
you've doing about like five podcasts a
week aren't you
you're the ultimate frenchman
i've had to actually cut it down to one
a week because it's been like
way too hard i've been getting caught up
with other work at the moment so
one a week's about me max so yeah
looking forward to getting into this one
so anyway
we'll crack on into this one and we'll
we'll start right back at the start for
you
tell us a little about what it was like
for you growing up
yeah growing up for me was uh i've
always thought
we grew up pretty good we were born and
raised in auckland yeah
um i was always a cute boy i've been to
man of the primary school
i stayed in one spot the whole time you
know yeah yeah
and um they clicked on and played uh
played my rugby
eighth grade rugby at a club called eden
yeah club
yeah so uh and this is what i was
playing
me and uh francis lee oh that's right we
grew up playing um
club rugby free there and then went on
to um
to high school infamous none of the
grammar school
well educated and the uh chocolate
doughnubs
[Music]
were you a bit of a gun at this age uh
no i was uh i was i was a stick in high
school
yeah yeah i was just behind i was just
um
i was actually i was actually glad and
um
blessed have been able to play footy at
the level that i was at but i think that
was just a
testament to the people that i hung
around and most of my so i had about all
my mates were all
rugby players which was you know which
was a good thing and the standard was a
you're going to become a rugby player
sure yeah and if you didn't it was
no but it was good so um one of my mates
was
um in high school stephen law tour yeah
and then there was willis
you know yeah that's like like i said
crazy they kicked on yeah
willis was the man in high school but he
went off to being again nothing done his
own thing and he'd
come back and then he's a man again he
was a man
he's so he's so humble like he's
been flicking me those those messages
yeah
yeah that's all it's been awesome to say
yeah
yeah so how did you go from high school
into
because you made um the samoa under 20s
eh was it
straight out of school yeah that was uh
straight out of school that one
we um uh me a couple of mates so it was
me
dolph stephen and joey tupe oh yeah and
yeah we all wanted to um we're all in
the auckland academy so we're straight
out of school into the
auckland academy system yeah and uh we
heard that the psalm on the 20s we're
going over to argentina
and we're just like oh man let's do this
you know we didn't want to
auckland academy we had to wake up in
like five years morning to run
run hills so i was like yeah
let's try and get on this plane and we
went
and you know someone the 20s you don't
run you have curry after training and
yeah
it was that fun and man it was such a
good experience they told us we're going
to get our
we have to pay our fair and everything
to get over to some more oh real
yeah and that's it they want to
reimburse us so like
i mean 12 years later there's still no
reimbursement
it's thirteen of play or nothing our
coach was um
yeah our coach was uh officer oh yeah
yeah yeah
so he was he was the man and we went
over there and
uh it was good it was a good tournament
we uh we want we won no games
we lost the tonga in the last game
yeah it's so bad it was i think we're
just there just enjoyable
yeah but you guys would have had some
good times off the field especially with
joe there geez
oh man we we won off the field
that was the problem you know we
off field we were charging there was we
just didn't turn up
we played we played new zealand and we
lost like 77
7. yeah i remember we scored the first
try and we're just like okay win this
your brother was playing too oh
[Laughter]
were you guys going out midweek and
stuff or just man we were going out
midweek
oh yeah yeah there was just a bunch of
us like the uh you know there was the
foreigner boys
yeah and then the local boys and the
foreigner boys were just all like all
right
she'll head out you know we wash the old
skinny jeans every night
one training session and then just
straight until then
oh yeah it wasn't really a taste of
professional footy
not good no i'm not quite have we come
back and we got in trouble
oh did you what was it no we just um
we come back and we sort of just kept so
we stayed on that we stayed on that
buzzer
oh yeah yeah come back in there we were
just
no good in there we got kicked out of
auckland academy what did you
who was that you know it was me joe
and no we didn't get kicked out we got a
warning oh yeah
yeah yeah it was me joe and
yeah they gave us the old talk down
about um well how we're playing up in
the gym i mean
we're there at the gym but we're sort of
not there in the gym was this before you
were
yeah you hadn't quite turned on yet
before it all made it all and we just
got
and then we played that weekend we had
to play club rugby and then we we turn
up
like we just went hard and and then done
our thing and then they're like
sweet as boys you know we don't want to
be kicked on
yeah but then uh we didn't quite we
didn't quite make it in um
auckland you know as far as we went was
what concerns
the uh wider itm and it was just huge
and then i decided just to move down to
taranaki just for opportunity and then
play there at the mighty spotty dogs
what a club yeah so
i took the wuzza and was a um
to me to come down there because we
played in these series together
yeah so how did the new zealand sevens
come about because obviously that was
before you moved down to the nekki
yeah so um was that a um was just uh we
had a tournament
and was that grandma carlton i remember
and um
titch was there just they were just
playing
and then uh i think we won that
tournament and in such a moment he's
just like hey
um like to uh if you can stay fit we'd
like to invite you to a camp
oh yeah i was like oh oh it's sweet and
obviously we knew we knew
our new gold pitches right here just
like yeah i was pumped i was pumped i
was about
19 then yeah and um
i remember going to my first camp and um
i didn't train because i was injured i
think i was but
i was able to just watch him and then i
was like oh
[Laughter]
so we had that we had that camp it was
like a two-day camp
and then we went back home that weekend
and we come back the following monday
yeah and man i remember i was injured
that one and then the following monday i
knew i was
i was gonna do it so it was like it was
such a wake-up call
i remember i was like yeah
it was uh it was tough man
and i can't even remember what i've done
i remembered half
when i left oh do you know um yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i remember coming back home and he
was just like oh well um i'll pick you
up in the morning
we'll go to do some ludus you know the
leadership yeah yeah
and i was like oh yeah what time is that
oh yeah 5am then
and then he walks home like
he picked me up the next morning i'm
like sweet and it was just
hard was it yeah
and on that sunday before that camp
he reckons okay let's go for a training
session or like sweet
we go to boxing alley and then he chucks
me in the ring with monty beatham for 15
rounds
you've always been a bit of a boxer
though hey where did that when did you
start there
oh man that was back in the day what was
that yeah it was the old man oh man it
was a boxer
all my uncles and cousins were all
boxers and true but then yeah did you
knock monty out
i think i think i was um spying or felt
you know
without hitting the head oh yeah yeah i
think i accidentally clubbed him one you
could tell he got a bit
i think he got a bit weird
you know when he shakes he shakes his
hands and he's like
[Laughter]
good stuff so then what about that
sevens cam what else do you remember
from there
did you dominate the testing and stuff
you must have impressed because
you made the squad i remember the um
they said that 13 was the level you had
to get
for the uh big test oh yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah you know we know i mean
you walk that's a walk in the park for
you but
i remember just thinking about it on the
ride down there
and then the night before you're just
like
and then you go to the door and you get
to about 10 and i'm like holy moly
i'm going i'm going oh god
and i remember i had um belgium thoughts
on the law next to me oh yeah
yeah belgium mark jackman and bryce him
oh yeah yeah they were running and then
um
i remember belgium
i was like holy
i don't think i made it i think i got
about like 12
5 or something oh true but my legs are
shattered like it was
it was fully dead i was just like man
and they go oh yeah we'll give yous
about um
30 minutes or so just to walk it off and
then we'll into the phosphate
yeah that's right that's brutal
[Laughter]
you're going to get much resting all
that lactic acid all still in your legs
yeah so it was that was what um 10 40
meter sprints eh
yeah and what was the turnaround on
those oh it was every 10 seconds or
every 10 seconds
every 10 seconds so if you if you ran it
yeah i was just like
and i remember um bryce remember bryce
and
um timmy went before me and dj
oh yeah and then we're just like going
after those two was the worst
like every single time yeah i was just
like
you know
oh they were just jumping on and after i
just collapsed and they were just like
all right
we head back home and recover and then
you know we got a field teaching that
afternoon i was like oh
man you obviously dominated the field
session though
oh man i had to somewhere somewhere
in my mind i was just thinking man
contact
i could not wait for contact or some
sort of contact
yeah because running was just but then
you make one tackle and seven then it's
everything all the air is just blowing
out of your lungs yeah
but what was it like getting named in
this in that team
you know it was rewarding though you
know i remember
making i remember when my name got
called out i never knew
who got caught after me i was just so
pumped yeah yeah
you know that feeling i was just like
well this is mad
and then uh what's what sucked him
because um
we left the room and the other boys were
still in there oh true
yeah i was happy as though because i was
like oh sweet but then we had a training
session
that was just like oh i was like oh now
the numbers have
been cut down it's like literally died
and then what tournament did you play uh
our first one was the gold coast yeah
that was
the one we debuted and um i remember we
had a few guys
um new to the team that this season so
there was about six
new guys yeah the only one playing now
is um
i think uh sam dickson oh sure yeah
that guy's a horse though he done his
acl hadn't run come back to the beat
test and then like
got about 15 or 16. just
natural eggs thank you let's go back to
your um
taranaki times so you traveled down
there you you were just playing club
rugby with spotswood
and you i think you were a truck driver
too weren't you or something
was that jd hickman man it was the best
i had this little hondo man and it was
good i didn't have a truck license
yeah and they're just like oh this one
you could get by and
and blair claire duffy the owner there
he was just like he loved rugby
yeah so he was just like just do your
thing and when you had training just um
just let me know and then just park your
truck up and head over to training oh
yeah
oh yes my first week mate i was that
time i was the hardest worker
i was driving everywhere and then the
second week i was just like
hey bro i've got training at 12.
sorry i got training at 11 am this
morning and then i'll be back
but i promise you man the bakery there
in waitana was
also it was just my reference to cruise
there before i drove down to harvard
what was your go to oh right that was a
good old steak and cheese
coffee oh i can't beat it always
surprise me how do we play debate on the
podcast other thing
what one no they just um
everyone here they reckon the uh
australian pies are better than new
zealand oh true
but i'm taking our pisces
we're going out there where was it out
there
yeah so then how did you make um the
taranaki team
how did that happen um i think it was at
the end of
a club season we went well and um
i came into the itunes cup squad at the
end of that season
and now this is when i don't think the
boys did too well that year
oh yeah yeah and i remember coming in
the last few weeks
um coops wanted me to come in just to um
get some experience
and stuff like that and then um after
that
and that break he offered me a contract
and i thought oh yes we must have done
something right yeah
yeah and then after that just
charged on and and your first full year
was 2014.
is that right and you made an instant
impact obviously
leading taranaki to their first ever
title what a year how skipper that year
was
he was the next level
and that was a good year for you though
because you were injury-free you played
a lot of footy
you were the key man at number six just
playing consistently good footy every
week it was awesome
oh you're making me sound way better
than i was
[Laughter]
right well that was a good dose man that
was the best year
yeah that was that was awesome man and
tazzy's gone on to
still be gone yeah you know boys are
kind of dropped off
i always remember that final like
there's so many there's so much sort of
like
fights and stuff in that final and i
always remember being
safe having you next to me the
semi-professional boxer ready to duck
and weave him
somehow we had uh how do we scuffle with
jimmy callum oh yeah yeah
that's right i was fully inside
i was like here and then
[Laughter]
the lungs kind of went so i was like
okay
oh that was such an intense game the way
that final was
next level that was mean and it was so
good to win that one that was
everything kind of worked well for us
that year right yeah yeah
those are the days and then obviously
your form was good enough to earn
yourself a
super rugby contract and the hurricanes
picked you up so you went straight down
there the following season eh
yeah and that was cool too it was um
that was also it uh it was a dream come
true man just to play
just to um be in any super rugby
environment you know
obviously i grew up um a blues fan
like yeah like crazy but um be
picked up by the canes i thought man
that's pretty cool i remember plums
coming in
in 2014 the week before the auckland
game
oh yeah yeah yeah i remember we spoke
and i didn't know he was the uh
hurricane's girl that's true
yeah he rolled into like his um his
three quarter pants and his
candles you know his genders and i was
like oh
he's like he goes out there he goes he's
like hey hey
you you're playing pretty well i was
like
[Laughter]
he comes down and he has his uh has his
hurricane jacket
and stuff going and keeps us i'm saying
oh i said this is plums he's the uh
false coach from hurricanes
[Laughter]
just brushed them off i brushed them off
at the uh their fans signing
oh [ __ ] yeah like oh damn it
he's a lady yeah he's good he's coming
on next actually
he's not like that isn't he a martial
you obviously didn't annoy him enough to
stop him from giving you a contract
because he's he's got you down there
and you two worked well together yeah he
looked after me he was
he was always um it was funny when i was
getting injured
and you know plums there clowns was
always just like hey you need to just
get your body right in just you know
like man harder not to bone into
something
oh yeah yeah all right
[Laughter]
but man you had such a it's such a bad
run of injuries at the canes
it was just like that was probably the
worst i've ever had yeah
so what was it what started it all i
remember
it was a i remember we trained hard that
first preseason
yeah and uh and it was probably one of
the best presents i've ever had because
i was i was geared up i remember
training then um we had
yeah i mean we had up camping dizzy and
then um
we had a game in uh katsuhuna yeah
yeah we had uh crusaders and i remember
gary and i was like oh yes we
and then the whistle blew that after the
first 20 and i came on for the second
spell
and i was like oh yeah bro this is man i
remember i had arty on the open and i
had bread
oh yeah what a treat when i was in the
booth i was in the booth i was
the boys made it made me feel
comfortable and i remember we were just
playing playing playing and then um
i got a short ball from bt oh yeah
thompson yeah and we got a shot from
and then i had um robbie faron and um
the frank's oh yeah owen right i just
stuck
and then i just got clobbered and
i knocked the ball on i got up and then
my arm was just dangling
and i was just running around and man i
couldn't lift it and i was like shucks
what's going on here and then went back
and then
they just said that the um was just the
dislocation of my left shoulder
yeah that's where it kind of spiraled
man yeah and if i was out for that
six months i missed that whole season
that uh itm cop
yeah and and now yeah before i team cup
i remember coming back
and i played one week of club
and then um i broke my arm oh true
yeah all right i was like and that was
that was [ __ ] that got me that was like
another three months off and then like
come back and then it was like ankles
and knees
and he knocked her away i remember he
had knocks a
head knock as well
i was like i remember we did a line out
session indoors
and kilburning yeah and we were doing
the
we're just doing contestable stuff and
then i did one and i fell down on vick's
foot
oh yeah and then just rolled my eggs
beforehand goes um goes uh we got the
reds
we got the reds this weekend so you
played the devil game on the tuesday i
think it was yeah
and then um play on the saturday
and then we had their lineup session on
the monday oh and they rolled my ankle
and
oh heartbreak yeah yeah
i was just like i forced it though i
still try to go
i still try to go up and play that d-val
game yeah
just because i wanted to just who i
wanted to play and then
i just couldn't do it man yeah no body
just wasn't
good yeah and how was that to deal with
how was it to deal with mentally like
that's just consistent setbacks just
must have been tough it was it was
draining like to be honest it was just
like
i think i did everything right to
for my body you know um or the i was
eating right i was actually eating right
yeah i remember i remember i used to
pack my lunch and i used to commute from
the kapiti coast
you know um with uh i was staying out
there and i used to do everything like
religiously well
yeah well trained well the friends you
have
you just didn't stop you are
unbelievable
yeah but that's what made it that's what
made it real tough for me because i did
all of that i did everything right i did
what everything
uh everyone wanted me to do and then i
went and got injured
time after time at the time i don't know
i didn't know what it was
you know and i think what i didn't do
was
was uh rest when i should have and you
know the mentality was
always trying to out work in yeah you
know and
and then man just mentally it got to me
to be honest
i had stages where i started going to
the bottle even more
yeah i remember i remember we had i mean
when i was out there
there next year and then i was just like
oh
i've got it because i had all these
other guys coming through and they were
playing in front of me but i couldn't do
anything because i was injured and
yeah and then i kind of had a wee spell
when i was in the dark period of my life
where i was just going
i was battling a little bit of
depression and mental health issues and
yeah it was top food but then um
i managed to uh to speak out i managed
to uh
to link up with a mate who's a athlete
he was a netflix pastor
oh yeah yeah and it was good and uh
that time was good for me just to uh
release that burden
yeah because i was kind of holding it in
and i was coming in mucking around
and drinking on like a tuesday
you see i even noticed all that eh so
yeah you must have been pretty good at
hiding it you never
smelt like alcohol or you always turned
up professionally
yeah oh man it was it was tough here you
you're so you're alone you know you're
kind of alone and you're kind of
fighting the battle alone yeah
and you come in and you're trying to um
you're trying to give
good vibes and good energy so then so
then you become like a team
man so then our team can do better and
stuff like that yeah
otherwise if i was to come in and mope
around i didn't want to be like that guy
that was just like
negative yeah but i was fighting it
um i was definitely finding it i
couldn't i couldn't even speak to my
even my closest mates truly that yeah i
was
i was going through that phase in my
life and um did your wife know
yeah she seen signs and yeah and stuff
like that she had
birthing her she had family uh
not far yeah because there were times
where um she couldn't stand it and then
she went back
and then i just you know i just got a
bottle and hung out with mates
yeah it was yes it was just like
it was um it was a real bad um
dark place like i mean but it used to be
hard to talk about but now it's so
you know so comfortable just talk about
it because it's such a good thing to
come out of it knowing that
that what i did about reaching out to a
mate yeah
it kind of helped in that way because i
was just like he kind of went through
the same thing and then so we kind of
we kind of it is on the worse than my
one you know
when i share a story but um it just made
my way look so small
yeah problems that i had was so small
compared to his and
how happy he was and how how tough it
was for me but
then i got out and um i wouldn't uh if i
looked back at it no i wouldn't change
anything that's happened yeah to where i
am now because i feel like that sort of
that sort of set me up for what was to
come after then and
and uh life's just been good after that
you know i mean
we've managed to have uh two boys and
another one on the way so
oh the fridge
[Laughter]
so good but obviously it's like it's
such a common thing too especially in
rugby like you're always getting
setbacks there's always something
non-selection
injuries yeah things like that so it's
such a common thing to
um to deal with throughout your career
and it's awesome to hear people like
you being open about topics like this
being able to speak up about it
tell your struggles and how you got
through it i guess is the most important
thing and
sounds like just talking to someone who
you trusted and someone that had been
through
something similar was was what you
needed and look at you now
yeah i appreciate it man it is it is a
it is a sensitive thing to talk about
but also a good thing to talk about
and to spread awareness to just for
those that are
that are struggling their own battles
you know what i mean and it's um
good for you to have this platform where
you could be able to be like if there is
anyone that's going through their own
struggles
to know that you ain't learning just hit
up the fridge
[Laughter]
youtube you knew you always used to do
all your speeches for our um
for our team and stuff and you never
wrote anything yeah you're all just
straight off the cuff
yeah yeah if you're a lead
yeah i if everything was one thing that
i remember is
you could you could stand on the spot
and just give the mean a speech
[Laughter]
i think the thing was the year before it
was kane barrett who
did used to struggle at public speaking
used to always have like the
written down i think coops used to write
it so i just didn't take up a notebook
and just sort of talk but
and people started to love it and then
obviously when people say oh you're so
good at public speaking it
gives you some confidence and you feel
like the next time you're up there
you're like
geez i'm expected to be good here so
then
i know you try a little bit harder or
something i don't know it's weird
you're a good man you're awesome
so you're at the hurricanes for two
years and you didn't actually get on the
field did you
no no the body just didn't um stay in
tech
i was just i was running around in
masking tape
i
i'm trying to think of who i used i
remember i used to i used to see cozy
all the time you know
getting his calf
at the same time it was uh it was a good
learning in that space it was um
was to look after your body through the
right things and
but yeah i was just everything was just
rough man
but even though you weren't on the field
the team had like quite a lot of success
those two years
lost the final and then won the final so
how did how did you feel about all that
were you
did you feel like you're still a big
part of that uh
you know i was in and around it i
remember we had to do
um you know we used to play against the
main team yeah stuff like that and i
remember
i remember those are our favorite
sessions
you know i remember even when i was able
to um jump on the
to when i was training i remember those
and i was just like yeah we'll go hard
yeah
this is going on and i feel like we
contributed to that
in a bit of uh just cultural um
just a bit of the culture stuff remember
it was awesome yeah when the team went
over to south africa we got to do some
cool videos
yeah yeah they get a team pumped up it
was always a role though
yeah i remember like everything you did
it was you're such a big team man you
always it always looked like you're
putting the team first and
i think what you mentioned about the
opposition
is such an underrated part of a
successful team
if you're playing like a really good
team on that thursday before the game
man it makes such a difference it really
tests
tests the squad and when you've got the
depth like we had that year it just
makes it easier because you're playing a
really good team before the weekend and
you're getting really
tested plus we had like um
all the guys that were in front of me
were just they were just unreal
yeah like there was like odds still
bread there was blade there was
yeah yeah and but the cool thing about
it those dudes are like the most
coolest dude there yeah they're just
like
but um that of those games we used to
play again we actually had no choice we
had
we had water coming into a hot on used
to be like
[Laughter]
make sure you you know oh yeah okay
you've edited that speech yeah
there would have been that many f-bombs
every single word he said that's all we
understood we're just like
he's the guy he's a guy
[Laughter]
i was just like elba who's happy
and then it was actually really good you
know um
that season was awesome man and going to
the games just to
see the boys do their thing it was yeah
it was a vibe
man and the celebrations after the final
oh yeah i remember you being the real
mvp there
you were the real friends you went all
all three days
yeah that was that was amazing because i
had trained
the whole year
[Laughter]
oh man that was good that was good times
there
i remember that oh yeah i think i
remember you and the gray man you were
you're wrong
[Music]
so then what happened after the canes
what was what was next
oh i went back to taranaki and then
that's where we started getting back
into
sevens oh yeah we played sevens
ended up playing for taranaki and then
um
i played viviana to a seventh camp the
it's sevens camp
what happened was we went after that
season
hurricane says that we went to fiji for
um
uh rarotonga for an invitational seventh
tournament
and it was kind of tough because we were
there and we're playing having a good
time
but then the super rugby teams got named
on our last day
you know yeah yeah like i was like oh
shucks
the team's name and then um i didn't see
my name
in any other teams and i was like oh all
right then yeah
were you expecting it i didn't expect it
but i was hopeful yeah
it was like you know um i was just like
then i'm like
obviously my body wasn't in tech but i i
was kind of hopeful i'm like
give them an opportunity but yeah but
it's you know just such as life you know
maybe had to carry on
and we finished up that tournament in
varatong and come back and then
uh got my body ready to play sevens
again
and after that we um straight back into
the nz seventh fold
they went over to dubai they were played
over there and
and that was tough because i only had
about two weeks to prepare oh wow
yeah so i was running i remember running
on that field and i was about 108 kgs
was giving me every like like last
minute of the game
i was like i remember walks walks got
injured in their first
game yeah and said we were down numbers
oh sure
but it was good after that we went to
cape town and i felt a bit better
yeah just flew on from there and then
after
after that it was um japan came
to there's not japan offer or going to
the chiefs
for a um injury replacement oh true
yeah so it was that or japan but and i
kind of thought i kind of knew my time
in new zealand was done yeah i felt like
uh japan for me was kind of good for my
body
yeah and uh yeah i wasn't wrong i got
there
and man was good playing against guys
that were like half my side
so was that with quintetso is it yeah
[Music]
did you know much about japan before you
went and how did you find it once you
got there
no the last place i wanted to go to was
japan
oh true was that yeah no i just thought
you know the uh
language barrier yeah too hard yeah
because i've been to china before and i
thought it was gonna be like china
i mean i just thought
and then went to japan and i was just
like man this is
such a good place now we lived in a good
spot yeah food was amazing
and man we got three months off every
year so it was
hungry away that was the best and you
you had two boys at this stage two a
yeah so i had um
had my second boy in my second year oh
yeah japan
yeah so that was um awesome so how did
the family find it there
ah they loved it man yeah yeah a lot of
opportunity for us as a family to do
things was
was a plus going to japan yeah we're
able to
um you know obviously we train in the
morning when you kind of have the midday
so you know really enjoy yourself and go
have a look around
come back in the afternoon train yeah
and then we had a thing called golden
week in japan
you know the golden week yeah and then
we got to like
we went to vietnam we went to thailand
um other countries oh we just we had
heaps of places
so yeah oh bless man
it was it was good to be able to travel
with the kids and
stuff like that so you did two years
with kontetsu was it
yeah two years kintutsu and then my last
year at the
tg take a guess man that was the best
was that yeah and i'm so glad so they
were the three were they
yeah oh true so how was that was that
just training mond uh tuesday thursday
nights or something yeah
oh real real okay it was the best like
that was the best footy man yeah like we
used to pump teams like 80.
[Laughter]
five tries oh
there was just no kid in the world and i
was just like yeah
let's do this and then just enjoyed us
enjoyed ourselves there
you know obviously the boys are good the
jet boys are good
made a lot of friends yeah he's he said
the jet boys still
messaging and good dudes
did you pick up the language at all
sort of yeah yeah so you could speak
with the japanese guys all right
in japanese or were they speaking
english
well it's funny because we didn't have a
translator oh you didn't oh
true yeah so i was out there just
because you must have been pretty good
there oh
man we all became fun
because you would have been running the
game that would have been tough yeah i
ended up
mainly playing fullback mainly because
of that reason i think just because it
was just too hard oh
yeah that's a you're a cool a yeah cola
yeah
so then even even though toyota gas was
cruisy
enjoyable yes still once that season
finished you still had had enough yeah i
kind of um
i knew that was gonna be the the year
yeah i remember i was kind of over it in
osaka
in that second year yeah even i thought
even i thought then i was just like oh
man i don't know i don't know about this
one and then um
plus it was world cup it was world cup
here and it was because i remember
shocking
um so i had a shockey they were either
coming to nagoya oh sure
yeah and i was just like oh and then so
i ended up taking up tgg
like we were right in the city we're
right in shibuya yeah we're pretty much
not even far
oh really and that was just a spot and
it was good
we had a good bunch of boys there as
well yeah
yeah it was a bad group too like you
know sam nor tonight
yeah yeah yeah so he was he was there oh
true
yeah it's crazy over in japan you see
all these names you're like oh where's
this guy been for the last
10 years he's been here right just
slowly dropping down the divisions
it's like some guys are like 40 you're
like broccoli
retired like 10 years ago you just find
him here i remember we played this other
team in the same
division and they said that radhiki had
just finished the year
oh that's true
[Laughter]
just keep going well that's the place
where you can keep going yeah because it
is pretty crazy especially if you're at
a place like tokyo gas and two nights a
week it's
it's not the worst gig yeah man it was
good man it was such the best vibe
and plus was right in the middle of
tokyo yeah
every single foreigner in tokyo like
you just hung out yeah you know no
matter where you were you just come out
from wherever you are and just come into
the city and
just catch up there we're pretty much
there soon it was always good just to
catch up and
tokyo was good and the world cup on that
was a massive buzz around japan so uh
heaps of people came from everywhere as
well so
how was that for you that was good man i
was pumped
like we were right there and like that's
what we're waiting for a year
i remember we had um i remember we had
to
we had uh training on the saturday of
the
first oblax game oh yeah yeah and i
remember caught up with adi
on the day before no the thursday before
yeah and then um um he was just like oh
i've left the tickets
left tickets for you and um for you and
your wife at the um
the reception and i'm just kind of
grabbing i was like oh yes
and i remember our training went off for
ages and i was just like
just like oh freak i've got a sore
stomach
and one of our coaches he's like uh he's
a kiwi lad as well yeah
and he he knew but he wanted to leave as
well
so he was just like he was just like i
remember i left
and then i stopped in at the 7-eleven
and i come out and he was on those
scooters
i was like he must have caught the same
buggers
[Laughter]
we got home we got home and i shot down
to the um
to the hotel where the avs were and yeah
and i went to the reception got the
tickets and i was guessing it back i was
in my scooter i only went about 60 miles
man i was just gassing it and then it
just stumped only we made it to the game
just in time and it was it was amazing
yeah nick's leave away so good we we
were lucky
they they let us they said if you got
tickets for any game you don't have to
train or you could have the
the weekend so i was just texting all
the boys saying
chances just trying to get out so i got
to as many games as i could eh
how many games you go to i ended up
going to about eight or nine i just like
[Laughter]
yeah it was good time [ __ ] it was a good
world cup oh man how cool they
yeah it's good time to be there yeah so
obviously you were training only
the twice a week so you that's what must
have been when you started getting heaps
of
content work for you with your
photography and stuff
yeah man it was that was and that was
part of the other reason why i did want
to go
yeah to take your guess was because just
the more
stuff i was able to capture yeah in
like in terms of content and man just
the amount of the amount of times we
were out
in just the city man the town just never
went to sleep
yeah night time was just cruising
and just capture heaps of just photos
and videos and just
piece stuff together yeah even just um
collaborating with other creators there
in tokyo you know what i mean yeah it
was it was the best
was the best part and just learning
heaps of other creators
was awesome that's so cool and you you
said you're self-taught you've just
taught this all yourself off youtube
that's
that's so cool yeah yeah yeah man it's
just been um
every day even now like sometimes i
still look on
youtube if there's anything that i i
want to learn and yeah
you know and but man now i just
now just the mind just ticks every time
now like i just can't sit still and
sometimes i watch the tv and i'm just
like man i got an idea
yeah and then i'll come up into the
office and then i'll put stuff together
and i'm like oh that looks pretty cool
the ultimate fridge mate the best
warranty in the business as well
it just keeps going lifetime warranty
i'm gonna make you a free jay i'm gonna
do what i was just gonna make your
fridge and check the speed out together
or what a fridge
[Laughter]
you've got a you've got someone doing
some good graphics and content for you
too
yeah it's been awesome hey april she's
just reached out to me came to
do some graphics to help the podcast she
liked the podcast and she was like can i
do your graphics i'm like
yes please thank you so much and it's
been awesome it's made a massive
difference because it obviously looks
way more professional and i just get a
bit more of a wider reach so
i'm looking forward to what she comes up
with for you hopefully
fisher and michael fridge
yeah that was that was yeah i see i seen
one of the posts i see one of the posts
you had i think it was
i can't remember who it was for i think
it was for lonnie and oh
yeah yeah i remember i just i remember
just rolling i was like oh
there's the fridge doing graphics
i was like oh the fridge is uh i think
it's the content creator now
no not me that was good though i was
thinking [ __ ] lonnie's lonnie's fighting
this weekend
he's right in yeah that was that was
awesome man
that's good though it's good i love it
eh it's awesome
now that's where i get through get my
buzz now yeah
so what's the plan what's the plans from
now have you got much of many goals or
anything set out for it or you're just
looking to
keep growing yeah i just want to be able
to produce something
soon you know i'm going to do it a bit
of
i i have i have a lot of stuff on my
mind like just some passion projects
that i want to do like a couple of these
like um small film type vibe stuff there
oh that's right
yeah i did want to do a bit of a mental
health piece
yeah at some stage but just um at the
moment it's just um
getting around to doing it you know um i
think i'm busy at the moment i've
i've uh put a lot on my clay you found
heaps of other content stuff that i'm
doing for clients and
and mate and stuff yeah but um years
from now i hope to one day be able to
produce a short film or training and
stuff like that
oh yeah that would be a good
short film man
would you do long ones would you do a
movie or anything or is that a little
bit
out of the reach oh that's oh it's not
just i don't know i don't know if it's
um
i mean i'd love to be a part of a team
that does um produce a movie oh yeah
you know i'd love to be part of that but
um
at this stage i think um i think i just
want to do something short for now
yeah and just see how that tracks and
just get along and
be able to make myself comfortable doing
it yeah yeah
oh that's mean and what's up what's
ultimate for like a short
sort of film what's uh what's the
pinnacle of that
oh just um just stuff that's been able
to be played at like short film
festivals
oh yeah and stuff like that that's just
it's across video
and and also having like graphics on
like billboards and oh yeah
and stuff like that that's a goal you
know and like being able to drive
and pull up at a traffic stop and you
see some of your work on the bus
or the back of the bus or something
billboard or something that's probably
something that um
i definitely love to um have happen
in the near future but just gotta chuck
along these little baby steps at the
moment right
no doubt you'll be up on those
billboards in no time
your work's so good do you want more
work or do you want people
can people reach out to you to get you
to make more content or you just
you just yeah oh at the moment overload
but it's always it's always good to be
able to challenge to challenge myself to
do more stuff and yeah and other stuff
than all the
normal stuff that i'm doing so if um
most of my stuff said
it's on instagram yeah instagram page at
uh
or i a visuals yeah where most of my
work's placed and um
yeah just uh follow through if you want
any um
any content yeah def definitely i
highly recommend it tell the listeners
go check that
go check out the instagram there's some
unreal content on there
and also your podcast but also if you
like it good
island laugh so good what's that on is
that on all
podcast platforms yeah it's all on now
um
it's all on apple podcast spotify and
and the youtubes yeah good have you got
any
have you got any plans for that are you
just looking to chip away with that too
just pretty
casually or just chipping away chipping
away at the boys so it's doing stuff
with the boys there
um doing stuff with um ads and enjoy of
uncommon yeah
and some stuff of um sure is like it's
one of the other boys paul brown that
says um it's their stuff that we're
uh oh true i need content with as well
oh nice
you're on how good geez i'm looking
forward to following this
you're going to be on fire but anyway as
always we've gone to our instagram
for some questions in the fridge oh
he's come up with a few today here we go
there we go um what's your role with far
east clothing
um no we're just um we're just
collaborative
like um one of the boys chris chris is
um
we're good mates good mates from home
and we're just bouncing ideas and trying
to push his stuff and
i'm in the content space he's in the
clothing space and he's pushing his
brand out and at the same time we're all
just
polly boys mucking around and doing
yeah good stuff okay this next one
who wins chris brown or you
oh definitely it's definitely uh
definitely physically
you can dance away you can
there's no way who touched me up there
joseph toei hey
my god okay
what's your best memory of ori's
oh worries man what was that um
what was that drink of suffering did you
play many games for them
hey i think i played i think i played uh
three games oh sure oh man the culture
was so good what was that
yeah and i broke my arm i broke my arm
and one of them oh true
it was good yeah i remember we're always
down at the uh what's this
cinema there in miramar oh yeah i know
the one
yeah foxy yeah roxy yeah roxy yeah i
think
yeah i remember always there with some
of the boys
nice okay who's the last player you'd
get in the boxing ring with
the last player yeah who would you least
want to fight
[Laughter]
no but he sounds like a nightmare yeah
he's a
yeah he's a nightmare he's he's really
he's ruthless probably who's the
skeleton there big
oh well skeleton oh lead
one punch from that girl
did you and um willis ever scrapped
growing up he used to be a bit of a
scrapper right
hey willis yeah was he no sharks
willis was such a bluff man
the tough luck
i thought he used to do the like ring of
fire or something
i will tell a story but i don't want to
embarrass you that would have been funny
he knows the foxy you know the aspiring
match in
high school what did you get him
no oh god i'll tell the story i'll tell
you yeah
so anyways i remember we had a first of
steam with first of the
training yeah it was um and we had
sparring so it was only body
body shots of body shops yeah and um our
captain he was just his name's ben
richards that's all
white fella and um willa said well this
was mine for like you know
yeah and our captain ben richard is our
captain he's a he was a lock
i remember willis just warming up on the
side he was kind of
he was going hard down he's like he's
like watch this
and all of us start surrounding the box
and he's sparring and ben just smokes it
right in the stomach
well that's literally that they drop on
the knee and then falls down to the side
and he's like okay i can't breathe
[Laughter]
oh oh that's funny
good one okay this one's from your good
mate hugh renton
do you still do leave-ins breathing
techniques
wait he wasn't big he was a big breather
right here
in that time of that time and i was
going through all the all my sessions at
rehab and
injured huey was always he was always
there with me yeah
he was he wasn't playing no he was
always rehabbed and he was trying to man
he would have to be the ultimate fridge
yeah you're right he does he
he neither stops he's still going yeah
so good to see you though yeah so good
to see you here we're doing so well
for sure okay next one favorite end of
season do
you would have had a few oh
i don't know well probably uh probably i
wanted to
probably in my case
i just loved all those interviews
yeah remember where we had one that
crowded
that's right everyone was jumping off
the um
roof yeah that was wow
that was unreal that was a good that was
a good time there
okay two more favorite country that
you've been to
i have to say um
i like dubai oh yeah i like people but i
have to say
um um raritong i still love varatonga
is
okay last question one piece of advice
for a young kid coming through
the rugby scene uh
look after your body don't trust the
system
and uh speak out if you're going for
anything oh
wow three so good
sorry no they were they were three like
on the point man that was
some of the best advice you'll get
covered everything oh but what
what a journey mate what a what a career
that you've had so good
i obviously loved playing with you at
the taranaki
such an inspiration mate you were you
were so good and
unfortunate times at the hurricanes with
your injuries and stuff
i was just waiting for you to get your
chance to kick on but mate just
one of those things with injuries but it
was awesome to see you push through that
go back with the sevens and have an
awesome lifestyle over in japan and
what you're doing post rugby mate you've
you've just killed it and you're doing
something that you love which is which
is awesome and
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast and giving up your time mate
my man thank you so much for having me
it was always good to uh
to catch up ma'am uh you've been doing
well you've been doing heaps of good
stuff
the ultimate fridge now for those asking
me what the fridge is
now it's
[Laughter]
thanks for having me on fridge now this
is awesome no thanks heaps bro i
appreciate it
my man